miss occasioning who moved to Britain
from Germany takes advantage of every
sale and special offer he can find
he lives in Milton Keynes northwest of
London and he's afraid price rises and
shortages will be rampant post brexit
Kirchner is a prepper someone who
prepares the OTD GERD ha people who've
got money don't care they can afford
everything you can always get anything
for money but the rest of us will suffer
and vision to hang
I think conditions will deteriorate
radically I can see it coming the
tuition is a freshly mown curtain
killing and many other Preppers see a
potential disaster following a hard
grexit and the government's plans do
nothing to calm those fears 3,500 troops
are to be on standby in case of a No
Deal brexit so Dalton the bomb will move
after time the soldiers will be armed
and sent to keep order so at some point
they'll start shooting at people and and
that'll be the end of the road yeah what
do you mean done then they'll have a
little civil war on their hands time
bill ok here
preppers are afraid nothing will work
properly
including customs processing at the port
of dover the islands busiest harbour
Mamluk dawa currently it takes a minute
and a half to get a lorry through but
once Britain's out of the EU it'll take
about four minutes they're projecting
five mile tailbacks within 24 hours and
within the first week the traffic jam
will reach London the authorities are
also anticipating long traffic jams in
the event of a heart brexit food
deliveries will be hard hit Britain
imports nearly half of its food from
abroad most of it from the European
Union experts predict that fresh produce
in particular could be in short supply
certain foods like chilled foods that
are fresh foods that only have four or
five days life they have to move very
quickly from the supply chain and any
kind of delay will mean they just won't
be available there isn't any stockpiling
or or tragedy that will work at the
weekly market in Milton Keynes Misha
occasioning expects there will be less
products on offer but he seems to be one
of the few people here who worried about
it the majority in Multan Keynes voted
for brexit and most people here still
seem convinced Britain will get by just
fine on its own people will be foolish
and they will start stockpiling and that
may cause a problem but I think it's
something that's unnecessary I think you
know our food shortages won't happen if
people are sensible and shop sensibly I
think we've got to get on and do it now
we've got to claim back our sovereignty
we can't be ruled by Brussels anymore
mr. occasioning isn't leaving anything
up to chance
he picks up tips from other Preppers on
Facebook how to drive vegetables so
they'll keep longer for instance some
are even buying camping supplies to be
ready in case of power outages what's a
human strain what I've got on my shelves
here ought to last two months in parts
why more not to liking yeah I've got
enough in my freezer to get me through
another three months so that's no
problem problem yeah Misha occasioning
thinks anyone who isn't taking
precautions is naive he's even got a
plan B worked out if the worst comes to
the worst he can always return to
Germany after almost 30 years in Britain
you